So the Swift generics model is rooted in exactly the same ideas as C++ OX concepts. So some of the names are different, but the ideas are the same. So the equivalent to a concept in Swift is called a protocol. And a protocol is an abstraction that describes a set of types that have a certain set of common operations. Now, just like with concepts, you can compose protocols. So a protocol can inherit from another protocol, for example, meaning every type that conforms to the one protocol also conforms to all the ones that Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 184 recorded on April 29th, 2024. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we finish part five of our five-part interview with Doug Greger.
Swift 的泛型模型与 C++ OX 概念有着完全相同的思想根源。虽然有些名称不同，但思想是一样的。Swift 中与概念（concept）等价的东西被称为协议（protocol）。协议是一种抽象，它描述了一组具有特定共同操作的类型。现在，就像概念一样，你可以组合协议。例如，一个协议可以继承自另一个协议，这意味着所有符合该协议的类型也符合它所继承的所有协议。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 184 期，录制于 2024 年 4 月 29 日。我是 Connor，今天我和联合主持人 Bryce 一起，完成了我们对 Doug Greger 五部分访谈的第五部分。
In today's episode, we talk about safety in Swift 6, protocols, generics, ABI, and more. You mentioned that, you know, half of its lifetime has been working up to Swift 6, which obviously then sets off a bunch of bells in my head. What is the reason for that? And my guess is that it's because there are some big features that are coming in Swift 6 that are, you know, if the last couple of years hasn't necessitated, you know, a version bump or a major version bump. There's probably some exciting stuff that obviously the people that follow the Swift community and the Swift language probably have been teased about or know about. So, to the extent that you can talk about it, I would love to not leave our listeners hanging on what, uh, is coming in Swift six and what should get them excited. So feel free to answer those in, in whatever order you want. And maybe that's how we'll wind down.
在今天的节目中，我们讨论了 Swift 6 中的安全性、协议、泛型、ABI 等内容。你提到，你知道，它生命周期的一半时间都在为 Swift 6 做准备，这显然在我脑海中敲响了警钟。原因是什么？我的猜测是，Swift 6 中即将出现一些重大特性，如果过去几年没有必要进行版本升级或重大版本升级的话。可能有一些令人兴奋的东西，显然关注 Swift 社区和 Swift 语言的人可能已经被吊足了胃口或者已经有所耳闻。所以，在你可以谈论的范围内，我不想让我们的听众对 Swift 6 即将推出的内容以及让他们感到兴奋的内容感到悬念。所以请随意按你想要的任何顺序回答这些问题。也许这就是我们结束的方式。
And then we can dive and do a full blown, you know, history of the Swift one, two, three, four, five, six, or whatever you'd like to come back and talk about. But yeah, uh, let's see. Well, maybe let's start with Swift six. Cause I think it says interesting things about how Swift evolves. So we have not done a major version bump since 2019. That was Swift 5. And this does not mean that we didn't get new features in Swift. So we deliver new features to Swift every six to 12 months. So there's new release every six months, and usually it comes with major features. Since we declared Swift 5, we added a concurrency model.
然后我们可以深入探讨 Swift 1、2、3、4、5、6 的完整历史，或者任何你想回来谈论的内容。但是，是的，让我们看看。也许我们从 Swift 6 开始吧。因为我认为它说明了 Swift 是如何演进的。我们自 2019 年以来就没有进行过重大版本升级。那是 Swift 5。但这并不意味着我们没有在 Swift 中获得新特性。我们每 6 到 12 个月就会向 Swift 提供新特性。所以每六个月就会有一个新版本，通常会带有重大特性。自从我们发布 Swift 5 以来，我们增加了一个并发模型。
So async await and actors is the basis of the concurrency model in Swift. We added that in 2021 and have been refining it ever since then. We added macros support last year, and we've been involving the generic system and so on since then. So new features we just deliver on the annual cadence. There's no surprises here. So Swift has an open evolution process. So if you go to the Swift forums,
所以 async/await 和 actor 是 Swift 并发模型的基础。我们在 2021 年添加了它，并从那时起一直在对其进行完善。我们去年添加了宏支持，从那时起我们一直在改进泛型系统等等。所以新特性我们只是按年度节奏交付。这里没有惊喜。Swift 有一个开放的演进过程。所以如果你去 Swift 论坛，
you can see reviews on new Swift features as they're being discussed. And they're discussed in the community, then decided upon and implemented throughout this process to come available. So it's a fairly rapid turnaround from a programming language standpoint to have these features discussed, designed, rolled out pretty quickly. So why are we doing Swift 6? So Swift 6 has one major goal, which is that we are expanding on the memory safety that we've always had since the beginning of Swift time to include data race safety.
你可以看到关于新 Swift 特性的评论，因为它们正在被讨论。它们在社区中进行讨论，然后决定并实施，通过这个过程变得可用。因此，从编程语言的角度来看，这些特性被讨论、设计、推出得非常快，这是一个相当快速的周转。那么我们为什么要开发 Swift 6 呢？Swift 6 有一个主要目标，那就是我们正在扩展自 Swift 诞生之初就一直拥有的内存安全性，以包括数据竞争安全性。
Oh, wow. So the idea here is that the language statically has an understanding of where data is created and where concurrency is introduced, so that it can tell you whether you are leaking shared mutable state across concurrency boundary, therefore introducing a database. So there's no way to do this without breaking some source code, because there is some source code today that is accepted in Swift 5 and has data races that will necessarily produce
哦，哇。这里的想法是，该语言在静态上理解数据是在哪里创建的以及并发是在哪里引入的，这样它就可以告诉你是否正在跨并发边界泄漏共享的可变状态，从而引入数据竞争。所以如果不破坏一些源代码，就没有办法做到这一点，因为今天有一些源代码在 Swift 5 中是被接受的，并且存在数据竞争，这些代码必然会产生
errors in the Swift 6 language mode to diagnose the fact that there are data races here. And the goal is we want Swift 6 to be at a point where, you know, you already didn't have to think about memory safety in Swift. You just program. It's fine. We want that same thing when you're doing concurrent programming, that you don't have to worry about data race safety because the system is supporting you and will tell you when you've made a mistake. That's, that's essentially what the whole run up to Swift six has been about. That's really exciting.
Swift 6 语言模式中的错误，以诊断这里存在数据竞争的事实。我们的目标是希望 Swift 6 达到这样一种程度，你知道，你以前在 Swift 中根本不需要考虑内存安全性。你只需要编程。这很好。我们希望在进行并发编程时也能实现同样的效果，你不需要担心数据竞争安全性，因为系统在支持你，并且会在你犯错时告诉你。这基本上就是 Swift 6 整个筹备过程的意义所在。这真的很令人兴奋。
And that is going to, I mean, already I think Swift is, you know, in the space of sort of languages that get compared with rust, but definitely is going to elevate it even more because I, I know that, you know, in the space of sort of languages that get compared with Rust, but definitely is going to elevate it even more. Because I know that, you know, D as well, there's been lots of conversations about safety in D. I don't follow the D community that closely. But I do know that
而且这意味着，我的意思是，我认为 Swift 已经在与 Rust 比较的语言空间中了，但它肯定会进一步提升它，因为我知道，你知道，在与 Rust 比较的语言空间中，但它肯定会进一步提升它。因为我知道，你知道，D 语言也是，关于 D 语言安全性的讨论很多。我没有那么密切地关注 D 语言社区。但我确实知道
I attended certain meetings and meetups and those conversations have been there. Anyway, so in the system space, it is obviously the hot topic. you follow obviously the c++ conference uh circuit you know half of the keynotes in 2023 my guess were all about safety and c++ and you know i'm sure folks that you know uh have given you know these these safety talks um anyway so it's uh not my keynotes though not my keynotes but uh that yeah i imagine that that's gonna um cause a certain amount of uh whatever ripples or or waves in the uh because you know the white house documents whatever it was called got released and they had a short list i think of six languages i don't recall i don't recall swift being on that short list but maybe they were yeah um it was but they were yeah okay yeah so i mean this will i mean you've already made the short list, but maybe they were. It was. They were? Yeah. Okay. So, I mean, this will, I mean, you've already made the short list,
我参加过某些会议和聚会，那些对话一直都在那里。总之，在系统领域，这显然是一个热门话题。你显然关注 C++ 会议圈，你知道 2023 年一半的主题演讲，我猜都是关于 C++ 安全性的，而且你知道，我相信那些做过这些安全演讲的人……总之，这不是我的主题演讲，但……是的，我想这会引起一定程度的……无论是什么涟漪或波浪，因为你知道，白宫文件，无论它叫什么，发布了，他们有一个简短的名单，我想有六种语言，我不记得了，我不记得 Swift 在那个简短的名单上，但也许他们是，是的，嗯，它是，但他们是，是的，好的，是的，所以，我的意思是，这会，我的意思是，你已经进入了简短名单，但也许他们是。它是。他们是？是的。好的。所以，我的意思是，这会，我的意思是，你已经进入了简短名单，
but this is obviously already adding to that sort of argument for why Swift and, you know, how safe is it? Yeah. And concurrency safety, it's a really tricky one. So, like, I haven't seen a proposal in the C++ space, for example, to introduce concurrency safety. Rust has managed it using strict ownership rules.
但这显然已经增加了关于为什么选择 Swift 的论点，而且，你知道，它有多安全？是的。并发安全性，这是一个非常棘手的问题。所以，就像，我还没有在 C++ 领域看到过引入并发安全性的提案。Rust 通过严格的所有权规则管理它。
It's an interesting model. We found in Swift that that would be too onerous. So in Swift, the fact that we are very value type centric helps a ton because it is completely safe to share a value, like a value of value type centric helps a ton because it is completely safe to share a value like a value of value type across concurrent tasks because all the copies are independent and local reasoning wins but we swift has classes like with inheritance and people use this feature and so you can't share those in any meaningful way. And strict ownership, like unique putter style, good for concurrency, not so great if you actually have more interesting graphs. So a class in Swift doesn't have value semantics?
这是一个有趣的模型。我们在 Swift 中发现这太繁琐了。所以在 Swift 中，我们非常以值类型为中心的事实非常有帮助，因为共享一个值是完全安全的，比如跨并发任务共享一个值类型，因为所有的副本都是独立的，局部推理胜出，但 Swift 有类，比如带有继承的类，人们使用这个特性，所以你不能以任何有意义的方式共享它们。而严格的所有权，比如 unique_ptr 风格，对并发有好处，但如果你实际上有更有趣的图结构，那就不是那么好了。那么 Swift 中的类没有值语义吗？
No. They are reference types. types so structs and enums and anything built on them like uh arrays of structs and dictionaries of structs and so on all value semantics you can build pretty much anything out of a value semantic model and it's you know a copy when you when you pass it around so so is an array isn't a what type of thing is an array it's a a generic something, but what is, it's a generic what? Yeah. So it is a generic struct. Okay. All right.
没有。它们是引用类型。所以结构体和枚举以及任何基于它们构建的东西，比如结构体数组和结构体字典等等，都是值语义。你可以用值语义模型构建几乎任何东西，而且它是，你知道，当你传递它时，它是一个副本。所以数组是什么类型的？它是一个泛型东西，但它是什么，它是一个泛型什么？是的。所以它是一个泛型结构体。好的。好的。
That wraps the class and implements copy on write semantics. Okay. Gotcha. So copy on write is the way out, right? Because like in C++, you wouldn't copy a vector everywhere, right? That would be problematic. You pass them by const reference. Const reference doesn't give you actual guarantees that your copies are distinct from your source.
它包装了类并实现了写时复制语义。好的。明白了。所以写时复制是出路，对吧？因为就像在 C++ 中，你不会到处复制向量，对吧？那会有问题。你通过 const 引用传递它们。Const 引用并不能给你实际的保证，即你的副本与你的源是不同的。
Right. Copy and write does. Yeah. So with classes, we needed a better answer in Swift. And actually, we found it when I was chatting with you two at PLDI two years ago. There was an amazing paper there on fearless concurrency, which had a type system that was far more usable than what we've seen in any other language. And we worked with those authors to bring those ideas into Swift.
对。写时复制可以。是的。所以对于类，我们需要在 Swift 中有一个更好的答案。实际上，当我们两年前在 PLDI 上聊天时，我们找到了它。那里有一篇关于无畏并发（fearless concurrency）的精彩论文，它有一个比我们在任何其他语言中看到的都更易用的类型系统。我们与那些作者合作，将这些想法引入了 Swift。
And they are actually forming part of the backbone of Swift 6's data race story to make reference types like classes work much better. Interesting. Yeah. Well, it certainly sounds like a language in development that we, as two people who work at NVIDIA, the parallel programming company, should be paying more attention to. Does Swift have Atomics? Yes.
它们实际上构成了 Swift 6 数据竞争故事的骨干部分，使引用类型（如类）工作得更好。有趣。是的。嗯，这听起来确实像是一个正在开发中的语言，我们作为两名在 NVIDIA（并行编程公司）工作的人，应该给予更多关注。Swift 有原子操作吗？是的。
Okay. And does Swift have GPU support? Can I program my GPU with Swift? Swift does not compile to GPU. No. You could possibly make it do so. I assume that on Apple that there's some metal compute way of doing things. You can't program NVIDIA GPU with it today, I would imagine. But if you want to do compute on Apple, I would presume that there's something. Maybe I'm wrong about that, though.
好的。Swift 有 GPU 支持吗？我可以用 Swift 编程我的 GPU 吗？Swift 不编译到 GPU。不。你可能可以做到。我假设在 Apple 上有一些 Metal 计算的方法。我想你今天不能用它来编程 NVIDIA GPU。但如果你想在 Apple 上进行计算，我推测会有一些东西。不过也许我对此错了。
You can use the Metal libraries from Swift, certainly. But your actual code that runs on GPU would still be Metal. Okay, gotcha. Interesting. Okay. All right. So we should talk about the generics. We should talk about generics they're
你当然可以在 Swift 中使用 Metal 库。但你实际在 GPU 上运行的代码仍然是 Metal。好的，明白了。有趣。好的。好的。所以我们应该谈谈泛型。我们应该谈谈泛型，它们
so much fun the poor listener okay what do you want you want a rundown of the swift generic system um yeah yeah i mean you said that it's rooted in c++ ox concepts so absolutely start from how you got start start from the beginning of your there C++ OX concepts is rejected, then you start working on Swift, and what do you come up with? Yeah, we come up with something that is very similar, but without the holes. So the Swift generics model is rooted in exactly the same ideas as C++ OX concepts. So some of the names are different, but the ideas are the same. So the equivalent to a concept in Swift is called a protocol.
太有趣了，可怜的听众。好的，你想要什么？你想要一个 Swift 泛型系统的概述吗？嗯，是的，是的，我的意思是你说它植根于 C++ OX 概念，所以绝对从你是如何开始的开始，从你的开始，那里 C++ OX 概念被拒绝了，然后你开始研究 Swift，你提出了什么？是的，我们提出了一个非常相似的东西，但没有漏洞。所以 Swift 泛型模型植根于与 C++ OX 概念完全相同的思想。所以有些名称不同，但思想是一样的。所以 Swift 中与概念等价的东西被称为协议。
And a protocol is an abstraction that describes a set of types that have a certain set of common operations. Now, just like with concepts, you can compose protocols. So a protocol can inherit from another protocol, for example, meaning every type that conforms to the one protocol also conforms to all the ones that it inherits from. Any type can describe that it conforms to a protocol, meaning it implements the interfaces required of the protocol. And it can do so with what's called an extension. So let's say I want to, I talked about this earlier, right? I want to make a Swift array conform to the equatable protocol. Equatable
协议是一种抽象，它描述了一组具有特定共同操作的类型。现在，就像概念一样，你可以组合协议。例如，一个协议可以继承自另一个协议，这意味着所有符合该协议的类型也符合它所继承的所有协议。任何类型都可以描述它符合一个协议，这意味着它实现了协议所需的接口。它可以通过所谓的扩展来做到这一点。所以假设我想，我之前谈过这个，对吧？我想让 Swift 数组符合 Equatable 协议。Equatable
protocol will say protocol equatable, and it will have a function equal equal in it that takes two values of type self and returns a bool. And so now I can write extension array that says array conforms to Equatable. That's going to be fully type checked. And the compiler will say, ah, no, you don't, because your equal equal operator requires that your element type be equatable. So you can correctly state, you know, extend the array type to make it equatable where the element type is already equatable. And implement any logic that you need to make sure that that is true. Generics in Swift follow the same notion as a constrained template. So you can write a generic. We still use angle brackets. Same thing as many other languages.
协议会说协议 Equatable，它里面会有一个函数 equal equal，它接受两个 Self 类型的值并返回一个 bool。所以现在我可以写 extension array，说数组符合 Equatable。这将是完全类型检查的。编译器会说，啊，不，你没有，因为你的 equal equal 运算符要求你的元素类型是 Equatable。所以你可以正确地陈述，你知道，扩展数组类型以使其成为 Equatable，其中元素类型已经是 Equatable。并实现你需要确保这是真的任何逻辑。Swift 中的泛型遵循与约束模板相同的概念。所以你可以写一个泛型。我们仍然使用尖括号。和许多其他语言一样。
And that template, that generic definition is separately type checked. There is no specialization. There's no overloading at instantiation time. So the separately type-checked body can never go wrong. Instantiation failures don't exist. And more than that, the generics can actually be separately compiled. So the actual default is you separately compile your generics, and the entire body is written in terms of these constraints on protocols. And that code will work for any type that conforms to the protocols, that meets the requirements of that generic function, even if you don't know about these types. You can ship a generic function in a shared library if you want and and use it with
而且那个模板，那个泛型定义是单独进行类型检查的。没有特化。在实例化时没有重载。所以单独类型检查的主体永远不会出错。实例化失败是不存在的。不仅如此，泛型实际上可以单独编译。所以实际的默认设置是你单独编译你的泛型，整个主体是根据这些协议约束编写的。该代码将适用于任何符合协议的类型，即满足该泛型函数要求的类型，即使你不知道这些类型。如果你愿意，你可以将泛型函数发布在共享库中，并将其与
unknown clients is that is that because it's like it's not like a static system like c++ but it's more like a type erase sort of thing at the implementation level it is i'm afraid of the word type erase the phrase type erased because there's very specific meaning in Java, which is that it loses the information about parameters. That information is never lost in Swift. It's maintained, even though you don't know what the type is until runtime. There's metadata there that's passed along to the generic function to say what the type is. And you can always have that information. So it's not erased, but the implementation is essentially dynamically dispatched such that it can deal with any type that meets the requirements.
未知的客户端一起使用。这是因为它是像 C++ 那样的静态系统，还是在实现层面更像是一种类型擦除的东西？它是，我害怕“类型擦除”这个词，因为在 Java 中有非常具体的含义，即它丢失了关于参数的信息。这些信息在 Swift 中永远不会丢失。它被保留了，即使你在运行时之前不知道类型是什么。那里有元数据被传递给泛型函数以说明类型是什么。你总是可以拥有这些信息。所以它没有被擦除，但实现本质上是动态分派的，这样它就可以处理任何满足要求的类型。
Gotcha. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So there's indirection there. Yeah, that's, yeah. And we treat sort of instantiation in Swift is just a compiler optimization pass. So if you have access to the body of a generic function and you have a call to it with concrete arguments, then the compiler can go and do the equivalent of instantiation to create a faster version exactly for that type when it's profitable, when you have the information and it looks profitable. So, so, so yeah, I mean, what, what in C++, you essentially have two very explicit systems
明白了。是的，是的，是的。所以那里有间接性。是的，那是，是的。我们将 Swift 中的实例化视为一种编译器优化过程。所以如果你能访问泛型函数的主体，并且你用具体的参数调用它，那么编译器就可以去执行相当于实例化的操作，在有利可图时，当你拥有信息并且看起来有利可图时，为该类型创建一个更快的版本。所以，所以，所以是的，我的意思是，在 C++ 中，你本质上拥有两个非常明确的系统
where you have a way of doing templates which are instantiated at compile time. And if you want to do any form of dynamic dispatch, you either have to roll your own thing or you have to do inheritance and classes. And so it's sort of two worlds. Whereas in a language like Swift, it's one world where the generics can be optimized by the compiler in the places where it matters. People don't have to think about and deal with these two different things. It's a very C++-y way of doing things where it's like we care about the performance and we don't care if there's half a dozen ways of doing things.
你有在编译时实例化的模板方式。如果你想进行任何形式的动态分派，你要么必须自己动手，要么必须使用继承和类。所以这有点像两个世界。而在像 Swift 这样的语言中，这是一个世界，泛型可以在编译器认为重要的地方进行优化。人们不需要考虑和处理这两件不同的事情。这是一种非常 C++ 风格的做事方式，就像我们关心性能，我们不在乎是否有半打做事方式。
Sure. And in C++, you have mechanisms if you need them. Like if you don't want to instantiate the template for every use, you can do tricks, right? You can put std functions in there or you could use like one of the type erasure libraries. Yeah. They're available. I know Boost has an interesting one. I'm not sure what people are using today.
当然。在 C++ 中，如果你需要，你有机制。就像如果你不想为每次使用都实例化模板，你可以耍花招，对吧？你可以在里面放 std 函数，或者你可以使用像类型擦除库那样的东西。是的。它们是可用的。我知道 Boost 有一个有趣的。我不确定人们今天在使用什么。
Swift also builds that notion of type erasure into the language. So if you have a protocol, you can use it for generic constraints. You can also create a value of type any space and that protocol name, which dynamically erases the type that's been put in there and lets it vary at runtime. So let's say I want a container of strings. I don't care if that container is a set or an array or something else you came up with, right? In C++, I would write like a type erasure class of some sort that maybe does some virtual dispatch to do that. In Swift, you basically write any collection of string.
Swift 也将类型擦除的概念构建到语言中。所以如果你有一个协议，你可以用它进行泛型约束。你也可以创建一个类型为 any 加上协议名称的值，它会在运行时动态擦除放入其中的类型，并让它在运行时变化。所以假设我想要一个字符串容器。我不在乎那个容器是集合还是数组还是你提出的其他东西，对吧？在 C++ 中，我会写某种类型擦除类，也许做一些虚分派来做到这一点。在 Swift 中，你基本上写 any collection of string。
And the compiler handles that type erasure for you. The idea here is most of the time you should be using generics and keeping all that static type information because it can optimize well when you need to optimize it well. But if you really do need that indirection, you're going to deal with like collections of heterogeneous types, for example, then the same mechanism that is there and you can sort of like seamlessly shift into the dynamic dispatch world and back to the static world when you need to. This reminds me of another topic that I was neglectful in my role in not bringing this up, but Swift has a rather interesting approach to ABI resilience that I think is often talked about in the C++ world whenever our ABI problems come up. And maybe you can explain a little bit of how that's approached. Yeah, sure. So this is one of the things I think is almost unique to Swift.
编译器为你处理那种类型擦除。这里的想法是大多数时候你应该使用泛型并保留所有那些静态类型信息，因为当需要优化时它可以很好地优化。但如果你确实需要那种间接性，你将处理异构类型集合，例如，那么相同的机制就在那里，当你需要时，你可以无缝地切换到动态分派世界并回到静态世界。这让我想起了另一个话题，我在我的角色中疏忽了没有提出这一点，但 Swift 有一种相当有趣的方法来处理 ABI 弹性，我认为每当我们的 ABI 问题出现时，这在 C++ 世界中经常被谈论。也许你可以解释一下它是如何处理的。是的，当然。所以这是我认为几乎是 Swift 独有的事情之一。
There are very few languages with a stable ABI at all. C, C++, and the managed languages that are stable like at the bytecode level, but not necessarily at the low-level calling convention. And of those that do, they're not really built to make it easy to evolve something while maintaining an ABI. This is the challenge that C++ has always had, where it has a stable ABI and people do ship shared libraries of the standard library. But you really can't change anything in the implementation without breaking the ABI. It's very hard to reason about. We knew with Swift, as we were going into designing it, that one of the fundamental things we wanted to do was be able to ship system like platform libraries written in Swift.
很少有语言具有稳定的 ABI。C、C++ 和像字节码级别稳定但未必在底层调用约定上稳定的托管语言。在那些确实有的语言中，它们并不是真正为了在保持 ABI 的同时轻松演进某些东西而构建的。这是 C++ 一直面临的挑战，它有一个稳定的 ABI，人们确实发布标准库的共享库。但你真的不能在不破坏 ABI 的情况下改变实现中的任何东西。这很难推理。我们知道 Swift，当我们进入设计它时，我们想要做的基本事情之一就是能够发布用 Swift 编写的像平台库这样的系统。
And so a platform library is this interesting breed of library where it ships in the operating system and it's used from third-party apps. And users completely expect that they can update their operating system and their apps still work. Right. And maybe even get new features, which means the implementations need to be able to change without breaking that binary interface. And so in the design of Swift, we realized, okay, we have to not just provide a stable ABI like C++ does, sort of the de facto ABI that C++ has is stable.
所以平台库是一种有趣的库，它在操作系统中发布，并被第三方应用程序使用。用户完全期望他们可以更新他们的操作系统，而他们的应用程序仍然可以工作。对。甚至可能获得新特性，这意味着实现需要能够在不破坏二进制接口的情况下进行更改。因此，在 Swift 的设计中，我们意识到，好的，我们不仅必须提供像 C++ 那样的稳定 ABI，C++ 拥有的事实上的 ABI 是稳定的。
We actually need to make it deliberately designed such that teams that are working on these platform libraries can do like real serious feature development and evolve their libraries without breaking those interfaces. And so this is actually, it is a part of the language only in subtle ways that you don't see, but it's deeply embedded in the way that Swift compiles code when you are building a library that is meant for this. So, you know, stepping back to like the language itself. So, you know, imagine you are a vendor of a platform library and you have a struct, like a URL struct, right?
我们实际上需要刻意设计它，以便致力于这些平台库的团队可以进行真正严肃的特性开发并演进他们的库，而不会破坏这些接口。所以这实际上是语言的一部分，只是以你看不见的微妙方式，但它深深嵌入在 Swift 编译代码的方式中，当你构建一个为此目的的库时。所以，你知道，回到语言本身。所以，你知道，想象你是平台库的供应商，你有一个结构体，比如 URL 结构体，对吧？
It's a value type. You're going to provide some APIs on it. And you know, you, you know, at some point you're going to say, okay, I'm going to give this out to my users. Now, Swift takes the view that unless you explicitly make something public, no clients can depend on it, right? So you might have your struct, you can develop yourself. No one can touch it outside of your module. If you want to make it public, you slap the public keyword on it. And that means you must continue providing this thing or else you will break your client,
它是一个值类型。你将在它上面提供一些 API。而且你知道，你，你知道，在某个时候你会说，好的，我要把它给我的用户。现在，Swift 的观点是，除非你明确地将某物公开，否则没有客户端可以依赖它，对吧？所以你可能有你的结构体，你可以自己开发。没有人可以在你的模块之外触碰它。如果你想公开它，你就在它上面加上 public 关键字。这意味着你必须继续提供这个东西，否则你将破坏你的客户端，
which is both a promise on the source code side of things, like they'll continue to compile. When your library is built in this form, this library resilience form. It also means that clients will be compiled in a way that you can change any non-public detail of your type without breaking the ABI. So things like reshuffling your fields, fine. Changing the size and layout of your type, fine. You can go and do that because those are non-public details of your type. So mostly that's just the compiler sort of introducing in direction where it needs to when it knows that it's at a boundary where something underneath it can change
这既是对源代码方面的承诺，比如它们将继续编译。当你的库以这种形式构建时，这种库弹性形式。这也意味着客户端将以一种方式编译，即你可以更改类型的任何非公开细节而不会破坏 ABI。所以像重新洗牌你的字段，没问题。更改类型的大小和布局，没问题。你可以去那样做，因为那些是你类型的非公开细节。所以大多数情况下，这只是编译器在它知道它处于边界时引入间接性，因为下面的某些东西可以改变
and needs to maintain the ABI. And for the most part, it doesn't affect users other than we have other checking technologies to make sure that when you changed and delivered a new version of your library, you didn't actually break the ABI or break the interface. But it's a very pervasive system. So from the user perspective, you add this library evolution flag to the compiler, and now your code builds in a way that it is ABI stable. And you can change the implementation for your clients. Your clients will not even know that you did this because the language impact is zero for enabling this. This is actually super important that the language impact is useful because the same code needs to be able to run against a platform where like the Swift standard library is baked into the platform itself. It's part of the operating system and also run somewhere where
并且需要维护 ABI。而且在大多数情况下，它不会影响用户，除了我们有其他检查技术来确保当你更改并交付新版本的库时，你没有真正破坏 ABI 或破坏接口。但这是一个非常普遍的系统。所以从用户的角度来看，你在编译器中添加这个库演进标志，现在你的代码以 ABI 稳定的方式构建。你可以为你的客户端更改实现。你的客户端甚至不会知道你做了这个，因为启用这个的语言影响为零。这实际上非常重要，语言影响是有用的，因为相同的代码需要能够在 Swift 标准库被烘焙到平台本身的平台上运行，它是操作系统的一部分，也可以在某个地方运行，在那里
you don't have those constraints and you just want to not have any of these resilience barriers in there and compile down to even just one statically linked binary, for example. Yeah, I don't know any other language that has a system quite like us. I wish we knew of one so we could see if they had some ideas that we missed. So I guess it's a little late for us. But as far as I know, this isn't a thing that other people have tackled. Maybe Connor knows. Connor is the researchers here. He would maybe know.
你没有那些约束，你只是不想在里面有任何这些弹性障碍，并编译成甚至只是一个静态链接的二进制文件，例如。是的，我不知道还有哪种语言有像我们这样的系统。我希望我们知道一个，这样我们就可以看看他们是否有我们错过的想法。所以我想这对我们来说有点晚了。但据我所知，这不是其他人解决过的事情。也许 Connor 知道。Connor 是这里的研究员。他可能知道。
I do not know of any languages. And that was the talk that you gave at PLDI 2022 was on ABI evolution. And if I recall correctly, you kind of at the end of the talk said, you know, the point of this talk is, you know, I'm sitting in front or I'm standing in front of an academic crowd. And for better or for worse, this is not a topic of interest for most of you. You know, like I'm not sure if you said this, but, you know, it is true that 90% of, you know, PL research these days is in type theory and, you know, this ABI evolution, you know, different techniques, etc. It may not be as sexy and cool as, you know, Agda and all these different proof languages, but this is extremely important. And only folks in industry really care about this. And to be honest, there's not really that, you know, like you said, like, what are the other languages that actually experiment with this i cannot off the top of my head think of any really and uh maybe you could argue that rust with you know epochs uh or additions or whatever they ended up getting i think it's additions right um and then c++ it's not really the same thing at all no i don't i don't think rust's epochs thing provides any form of ABI resilience and C++'s Epoch proposal didn't either. Different thing. Different thing?
我不知道任何语言。这就是你在 PLDI 2022 上发表的关于 ABI 演进的演讲。如果我没记错的话，你在演讲结束时说，你知道，这次演讲的重点是，你知道，我坐在学术人群面前，或者我站在学术人群面前。无论好坏，这对你们大多数人来说都不是一个感兴趣的话题。你知道，就像我不确定你是否说了这个，但是，你知道，确实 90% 的 PL 研究这些天都在类型理论中，而且，你知道，这种 ABI 演进，你知道，不同的技术等等。它可能不像 Agda 和所有这些不同的证明语言那样性感和酷，但这极其重要。而且只有工业界的人才真正关心这一点。老实说，真的没有，你知道，就像你说的，你知道，还有什么其他语言真正尝试过这个？我无法从脑海中想到任何真正的东西，而且，嗯，也许你可以争辩说 Rust 有，你知道，纪元（epochs）或版本（editions）或无论他们最终得到什么，我想是版本，对吧，嗯，然后 C++，这根本不是同一回事。不，我不认为 Rust 的纪元东西提供了任何形式的 ABI 弹性，C++ 的纪元提案也没有。不同的东西。不同的东西？
There have been discussions in the Rust community around a stable ABI, but I haven't seen anything that is crystallized there. Okay, so maybe this is more API evolution than it is ABI evolution. But yeah, it's interesting, not even just with respect to this feature, but like the
Rust 社区中关于稳定 ABI 的讨论，但我还没有看到任何具体化的东西。好的，所以这可能更多是 API 演进而不是 ABI 演进。但是是的，这很有趣，不仅是在这个特性的方面，而且就像
disconnect between academia and industry when it comes to programming languages, because there seems to be, at least from my perspective, like a gap in the usefulness necessarily of the stuff that gets researched on versus the interest and sort of like academic nature of the work. And yeah, I'm not sure if you want to add anything to that, Doug. And I think that talk was recorded. If it is, I will definitely find a link and throw it in the show notes if folks are interested. I'm not sure if it was, but I mean, I was there in person, so I saw it live. If it's not recorded, maybe I'll try and find it. I'm not sure if you gave that talk again
学术界和工业界在编程语言方面的脱节，因为似乎，至少从我的角度来看，研究的东西的有用性与工作的兴趣和学术性质之间存在差距。是的，我不确定你是否想对此补充什么，Doug。我认为那次演讲被录制了。如果是的话，如果人们感兴趣，我一定会找到链接并把它放在节目说明中。我不确定它是否被录制了，但我的意思是，我亲自在那里，所以我现场看到了它。如果它没有被录制，也许我会尝试找到它。我不确定你是否再次发表了那次演讲
at a different venue that you definitely know it was recorded um there's a form of that talk that is more compiler centric that i gave at the llvm developer meeting and i can't remember if it was 2020 or 2021 okay one of one of the lvm developer, I gave a talk that was more about how we do code generation for this ABI resilience model. Whereas the talk that you're mentioning at PLDI was very much like, this is a real problem we have in industry that, yeah, it is getting ignored. I think it's really unfortunate that this problem is getting ignored because as it stands, how do we talk to our operating systems today? It's C, right? It's POSIX C interfaces, which is a little bit unfortunate, especially as we talk toward, well, we want to improve the safety of our systems for memory safety. Having to funnel everything through a C API to talk to your OS is not good for that overall goal, right? And this is part of where we for memory safety, having to funnel everything through a C API to talk to your OS is not good for that overall goal.
在不同的场地，你肯定知道它被录制了，嗯，那次演讲有一种更以编译器为中心的形式，我在 LLVM 开发者会议上发表过，我不记得是 2020 年还是 2021 年了，好的，其中一个 LLVM 开发者，我发表了一次演讲，更多是关于我们如何为这种 ABI 弹性模型进行代码生成的。而你提到的在 PLDI 上的演讲非常像，这是我们在工业界遇到的一个真正的问题，是的，它正在被忽视。我认为这个问题被忽视真的很不幸，因为现状是，我们今天如何与我们的操作系统对话？是 C，对吧？是 POSIX C 接口，这有点不幸，特别是当我们谈论，嗯，我们想要提高我们系统的内存安全性时。必须通过 C API 引导一切来与你的操作系统对话对那个总体目标不利，对吧？这是我们的一部分，因为为了内存安全性，
This is part of where we're coming from. But we want to build the platform APIs in a language that is both expressive and safe. And so we had to have an ABI there. But yeah, even new languages. I wouldn't say it's academia that's specifically at fault here. You look at brand new programming
必须通过 C API 引导一切来与你的操作系统对话对那个总体目标不利。这是我们的一部分，因为我们想要用一种既富有表现力又安全的语言来构建平台 API。所以我们必须在那里有一个 ABI。但是是的，即使是新语言。我不会说这是学术界的错。你看看全新的编程
languages they don't they won't commit to an abi right yeah and i understand the reasons you you do give up optimization potential and it becomes harder to evolve your compiler once you've locked down an abi yeah i find this stuff interesting from from like a pl point of view of of the stuff that kind of falls through the cracks like the other thing that comes to mind because it's topical zx or xz whatever that uh the massive uh almost like near miss of um and like that's that's completely oh wait i have i you've completely lost me what are you talking about you didn't you didn't hear about this bryce no it was uh do you know what order of the two letters it was doug it was it was either yeah xz xz the open source project yes was essentially socially engineered into yeah social engineering basically but like over over years. So somebody was contributing to this project for like two or three years and then inserted malicious code.
语言，它们不会承诺 ABI，对吧？是的，我理解原因，你确实放弃了优化潜力，一旦你锁定了 ABI，演进你的编译器就变得更难了。是的，我从 PL 的角度发现这些东西很有趣，因为那些有点从裂缝中掉出来的东西，就像另一件浮现在脑海中的事情，因为它很热门，ZX 或 xz，无论那个……大规模的……几乎像险些发生的……而且这完全……哦，等等，我完全失去了你，你在说什么？你没听说这个吗，Bryce？不，它是……你知道那两个字母的顺序是什么吗，Doug？它是……或者是 xz，xz 开源项目，是的，基本上被社会工程学诱导……是的，社会工程学，基本上，但是……多年来。所以有人为这个项目贡献了大约两三年，然后插入了恶意代码。
And it seems like the whole entire thing was a setup for him to insert malicious code. Yeah. But this is, I bring it up because it's one of these things that, you know, it doesn't really get talked about in the, you know, well well we got a program in memory safe languages and safely safety is such a huge topic but like this is another like it's adjacent to safety or should be under the safety umbrella but no one's talking about this stuff and like this would have been like this would this was like what do they call it uh you know level 10 like cve like this like it's getting it's getting uh you know access like, like SSH access. It would have just been, anyways. And I listened, I think, was it Brian Cantrell from Oxide and Friends?
而且看起来整个事情都是为了让他插入恶意代码而设置的。是的。但我提出这一点是因为它是这些事情之一，你知道，它并没有真正被谈论，你知道，好吧，我们必须用内存安全的语言编程，安全性是一个如此巨大的话题，但这是另一个，你知道，它与安全性相邻，或者应该在安全性的保护伞下，但没有人谈论这些东西，而且这就像……这就像他们称之为……你知道，10 级 CVE，就像它正在获得……你知道，访问权限，就像 SSH 访问。它本来会……总之。而且我听了，我想，是 Oxide and Friends 的 Brian Cantrell 吗？
He had a podcast where they had the Microsoft engineer that found it. And he, like his story of like how he ended up like noticing the perf difference. It was like, it could have been a gust of wind basically that uh caused him to not look at it and that is like that's terrifying that like it was it was pure coincidence that he happened to notice one thing a month ago he happened to not be super busy and so we all take some extra time anyway so it's this kind of stuff that like there's always these sexy topics in like programming language, whether you're a compiler writer or an academic in industry or an academic in academia. And then there's these kind of topics that don't get talked about as much and not just how are we going to get dependent types into Haskell and then into every other language. Because as cool as that would be, there's probably more important things that will have a larger impact on the industry of software engineering.
他有一个播客，他们有发现它的微软工程师。而且他，就像他如何注意到性能差异的故事。这就像，这可能是一阵风，基本上导致他没有看它，这太可怕了，就像纯属巧合，他碰巧在一个月前注意到了一件事，他碰巧没有非常忙，所以我们都花了一些额外的时间，总之，这就是这种事情，就像编程语言中总是有这些性感的题目，无论你是编译器编写者还是工业界的学术人员或学术界的学术人员。然后有这些题目，它们没有被谈论得那么多，不仅仅是我们如何将依赖类型引入 Haskell，然后引入每一种其他语言。因为尽管那会很酷，但可能还有更重要的事情会对软件工程行业产生更大的影响。
But for whatever reason, there's less folks with eyes on that stuff. It's hard to know. I mean, part of the nature of research is you often don't know what the ripples will be from your success. I mean, I would love people to be looking at, you know, what it takes to how to maintain a stable ABI. And if we had some formalism around the way we tackle resilience, so we have this abstract notion of like these resilience domains, like code that's compiled together
但无论出于什么原因，关注这些东西的人更少。很难知道。我的意思是，研究的本质部分是你通常不知道你的成功会产生什么涟漪。我的意思是，我很乐意看到人们研究，你知道，维护一个稳定的 ABI 需要什么。如果我们对我们处理弹性的方式有一些形式化，所以我们有这种抽象的概念，比如这些弹性域，比如一起编译的代码
and what optimizations you can do in there without breaking code that's outside of it. It's very ad hoc, like we think it holds together. I would love if someone went out and researched it and, you know, proved us right or wrong right or wrong and told us where the problems were. I don't know how to get people interested in that. On the other hand, we've pulled for research and seen things where people did chase a cool type system and it actually solved a real problem for us in the data safety realm. So I don't know. I don't know how to tell people to work on, but I would love seeing more wild papers at academic conferences. I feel like there's way too much of a group of researchers all get interested in the same topic and publish a ton of papers,
以及你可以在里面做什么优化而不破坏它外面的代码。这非常特别，就像我们认为它结合在一起一样。如果有人出去研究它，并且，你知道，证明我们是对的还是错的，并告诉我们问题在哪里，我会很高兴。我不知道如何让人们对此感兴趣。另一方面，我们已经从研究中汲取了经验，并看到了人们确实追求一个酷的类型系统，它实际上解决了我们在数据安全领域的一个真正问题。所以我不知道。我不知道如何告诉人们去研究什么，但我很乐意在学术会议上看到更多疯狂的论文。我觉得有一群研究人员都对同一个话题感兴趣并发表了大量论文，
pushing it forward and everything else gets starved out. And that makes me a little sad because there's a ton of wild ideas that got submitted that won't get, you know, the airtime that they need to turn into something cool. Well, hopefully with AGI right around the corner, you know, everyone's going to be able to make their own TV show and everyone will be able to make their own, you know, fully fledged with a language server and tooling and package management language language over a weekend so uh you know look look i i saw the face palm dog but uh we got it we got to mention ai they uh they they at nvidia they pay us a little bit extra every time we mention ai in the podcast what i haven't seen any of this money this is uh very upsetting to hear all right all right we got we got one more one more question for you doug and then we we we do
推动它前进，而其他一切都被饿死了。这让我有点难过，因为有很多疯狂的想法被提交了，但没有得到，你知道，它们变成酷东西所需的播出时间。好吧，希望随着 AGI 即将来临，你知道，每个人都将能够制作自己的电视节目，每个人都将能够制作自己的，你知道，带有语言服务器和工具以及包管理的成熟语言，在一个周末内，所以，你知道，看，看，我看到了那个捂脸的动作，Doug，但我们必须提到 AI，他们……他们在 NVIDIA，每次我们在播客中提到 AI，他们都会多付我们一点钱。什么？我还没看到这些钱，听到这个非常令人沮丧。好的，好的，我们还有一个问题要问你，Doug，然后我们必须走了，因为我们现在进入了第三个小时，我的麦克风现在上面有一个红灯，我想这意味着电池要没电了，看起来很不祥，所以这是我的最后一个问题，所以 Swift 已经成为你开始研究它时你认为它会成为的那种语言了吗？就像，它是否以你认为它会的方式演进？它是否以你预期的方式成功了？它的演进如何让你感到惊讶？这是一个大问题。我喜欢以大问题结束。
have to go because we're now in the third hour and my microphone now has a red light on it which i think means the battery's gonna die it looks ominous so so here's my last question so has swift become the language that you thought it would be when you started working on it? Like, has it evolved in the ways that you thought it would? Has it succeeded in the ways that you've expected? And how has its evolution surprised you? That's a big question. I like to end big.
我得走了，因为现在已经是第三个小时了，我的麦克风亮起了红灯，我想这意味着电池快没电了，看起来很不妙。所以，这是我的最后一个问题：Swift 是否已经成为了你当初开始开发它时所设想的那种语言？它是否按照你预想的方式演进？它是否在预期的方面取得了成功？它的演进过程又有哪些让你感到惊讶的地方？这是一个很大的问题，我喜欢以宏大的问题作为结尾。
Yeah. So I think the evolution path has been more or less what I expected. So, you know, in the early days, we were just getting the pieces in place for what we felt like was the minimum you needed for a general purpose programming language. And as we turn the corner to the point where, you know, we were writing system libraries in it and people were using it at a large scale, our evolution has sort of necessarily turned toward more niche things. So, you know, a macro system that gives you language extensibility but doesn't really change the way the language is used. Or an ownership system. So like move only types is one of the big new things in Swift world. And, but it doesn't really change the way you program in Swift.
是的。所以我认为演进路径或多或少符合我的预期。你知道，在早期，我们只是在为我们认为通用编程语言所必需的最小功能集打基础。当我们转折到开始用它编写系统库，并且人们在大规模使用它时，我们的演进必然转向了更细分的领域。比如，一个提供语言扩展性但不会真正改变语言使用方式的宏系统。或者一个所有权系统。比如“仅移动类型”（move-only types）是 Swift 世界中重大的新事物之一，但它并没有真正改变你使用 Swift 编程的方式。
It's been fairly stable for the last couple of years, five years, probably. And it's more about filling in the niches so that we can take Swift anywhere. And sometimes you actually need the extra performance benefits of like move semantics and knowing there is nothing going on behind the scenes that you're not privy to, right? To share performance or to fit in, you know, down in firmware or something.
过去几年，大概五年吧，它一直相当稳定。现在的重点更多是填补细分领域的空白，以便我们能将 Swift 应用到任何地方。有时你确实需要像移动语义（move semantics）这样的额外性能优势，并且需要确信幕后没有你不知道的事情在发生，对吧？为了共享性能，或者为了适应固件等底层环境。
And so I think that is the right evolution of the language. I keep wanting things to slow down a little bit. You know, the language can't grow forever. It won't. But we can continue to fill in gaps. So I think, you know, has it done as well as I thought? I think it's kind of a split verdict for me. So the uptake within the Apple circuit for Swift are young. And it's people that started with Swift for the first time and found exciting things.
所以我认为这是该语言正确的演进方向。我一直希望节奏能稍微慢一点。你知道，语言不可能永远增长。它不会。但我们可以继续填补空白。所以，它是否达到了我的预期？我觉得对我来说评价参半。Swift 在苹果生态圈内的普及还很年轻。很多是第一次接触 Swift 并发现其中令人兴奋之处的人。
And it's like a much more energetic and diverse group than we've had in other communities, language communities that I've been a part of. And I think that's been amazing. And it's been wonderful to see people pick up on some of the things we designed, hoping that they would be usable by everyone. The generic system comes back to that a lot for me because I love generic programming. But people are writing generic algorithms in Swift, like fairly new Swift programmers, and they're fine. It works well for them. That's been great to see. I want Swift to break out further from the Apple universe to really, you know, be the language people want to reach for, for whatever platform they're doing.
这是一个比我参与过的其他语言社区更有活力、更多元化的群体。我认为这太棒了。看到人们开始使用我们设计的一些功能，并希望它们能被所有人使用，这感觉很美妙。泛型系统对我来说经常浮现，因为我热爱泛型编程。但人们正在用 Swift 编写泛型算法，即使是相当新的 Swift 程序员，他们也用得很好。这很有效。看到这些真是太好了。我希望 Swift 能进一步突破苹果生态，真正成为人们在任何平台上都想使用的语言。
Because I feel like it's a great language for getting your work done right. And when we see reports of people that have done this, they seem pretty thrilled at what they've been able to do. But the perception is ever there that it's an iOS app language. And that's the thing that bothers me a little bit because I think it's so much more than that. Do you, when did you know that, or when did you feel that Switch was going to succeed? Did you like from the moment that you started working on it, were you confident? No, not that early. So, I think, all right. So, there were, I would say there's, there's actually three points, which are very, very clear for me.
因为我觉得它是一门能让你高效完成工作的优秀语言。当我们看到人们这样做的报告时，他们似乎对自己所能实现的目标感到非常兴奋。但人们总有一种看法，认为它只是一个 iOS 应用开发语言。这让我有点困扰，因为我认为它远不止于此。你，你是什么时候知道，或者什么时候感觉到 Swift 会成功的？你从开始着手的那一刻起就很有信心吗？不，没那么早。所以，我想，好吧。我认为实际上有三个关键点，对我来说非常非常清晰。
The first one is just when we actually introduced it and people were super excited and went out building cool stuff. Like the amount of cool things that people built in the first like two weeks of Swift being available was just amazing. The second point is in 2016. So this was Swift 3. Swift 3 was a major change from Swift 2. Almost not the same language in many ways. But it marked a complete shift from Swift kind of like being a language that was like a better Objective-C or a layer from which you used Objective-C libraries to like this is a language that has its own identity and feel. And like value, this is when we were really pushing value types hard and getting people to think differently, like to really use Swift as it was meant to be used.
第一点就是我们刚推出它的时候，人们超级兴奋，并开始构建很酷的东西。比如在 Swift 可用的头两周里，人们构建的酷东西的数量简直令人惊叹。第二个点是在 2016 年。那是 Swift 3。Swift 3 是从 Swift 2 开始的一次重大变革。在很多方面几乎不是同一种语言了。但它标志着 Swift 从一种“更好的 Objective-C”或调用 Objective-C 库的层级，彻底转变为一种拥有自己身份和感觉的语言。这就是我们大力推行值类型，让人们进行不同思考，真正按其本意使用 Swift 的时候。
And people picked up on that. And I think the third part was actually 2019 with Swift 5. When we nailed the ABI stability and we declared, it's ABI stable, we have the feature set that we need to move forward. That is the point at which Apple started shipping platform libraries written in Swift with Swift interfaces. That's the point of no return because ABI is forever, right? We are invested. This is the path forward.
人们接受了这一点。我认为第三部分实际上是 2019 年的 Swift 5。当我们确定了 ABI 稳定性并宣布它 ABI 稳定时，我们拥有了前进所需的特性集。那是苹果开始发布用 Swift 编写并带有 Swift 接口的平台库的时刻。那是没有回头路的时刻，因为 ABI 是永久的，对吧？我们投入了。这就是前进的道路。
And we can build on this for years and years to come. So we've done a lot of cool things since then. And there's a whole lot more coming. But that's when it's clear that this truly is the way forward. And you can look at other languages that have started in a corporate environment that never got to that point or failed before they got to that point. So, that was a major mark of success And we're still maintaining that ABI. And it's hard work, but it has not stopped us from doing major language features and revisions to improve the user experience. And as a final note, if after these four episodes, five episodes, six episodes, we don't know how many it was, you decide to go and check out Swift,
我们可以以此为基础在未来多年持续构建。自那以后我们做了很多很酷的事情。未来还有更多。但那时很清楚，这确实是前进的方向。你可以看看其他在企业环境中起步但从未达到那一点，或在达到之前就失败的语言。所以，那是一个重大的成功标志。我们仍在维护那个 ABI。这很辛苦，但并没有阻止我们进行重大的语言特性开发和修订以改善用户体验。最后提一句，如果在这四集、五集、六集——我们不知道具体多少集——之后，你决定去看看 Swift，
probably this should have been at the beginning. You have to make sure that you include the algorithms library. There's a standard library that ships with Swift. But I remember the first time I went and checked out the standard library, I thought there's a bunch of missing, missing like what I would expect standard algorithms. I think famously one of them was scan. And I was like, wow, this is just incomplete. And then sure enough, a little while later, I found the algorithms library, which had every single, I swear, every single algorithm that I thought was missing was there. They don't call it scan. If my memory serves correctly, it's called reductions, which is actually quite nice because uh that's the same name that closure calls it and it's kind of kind of reflects the symmetry between reduce and and scan where you know from
这可能应该在开头说。你必须确保包含算法库（algorithms library）。Swift 自带一个标准库。但我记得我第一次查看标准库时，我想，这里少了一堆我所期望的标准算法。我想其中最著名的一个是 scan。我当时想，哇，这太不完整了。然后果然，过了一会儿，我发现了算法库，它包含了每一个，我发誓，每一个我以为缺失的算法都在那里。他们不叫它 scan。如果我没记错的话，它叫 reductions，这其实非常好，因为这和 Clojure 里的命名一样，它反映了 reduce 和 scan 之间的对称性，你知道从
those two names you'll never guess that they have anything to do with each other uh but yeah make sure make sure folks if you check if you check out swift you got to include the algorithms library they got adjacent pairs to one of the few languages that calls the adjacent adjacent connor connor is just lost without a scan like if he doesn't have access to a scan and reduce he's lost without a scan too what are we talking about i'm i'm lost without a scan like you know we're all lost without a scan if you're an array programmer and you don't have a scan it's like what are we doing here what do got to write a for loop? Give me a scan and a reduce and I can dild you the world. Anyways, thank you so much, Doug. This definitely, I think, has set the record as longest recording.
这两个名字你永远猜不到它们有什么关系，但是的，确保，确保大家，如果你查看 Swift，你必须包含算法库。他们有 adjacent pairs，这是少数几个调用 adjacent 的语言之一。Connor，Connor 没有 scan 就迷失了，如果他不能使用 scan 和 reduce，他没有 scan 就迷失了。我们在说什么？我没有 scan 就迷失了，就像你知道的，如果我们是数组程序员，却没有 scan，那我们在做什么？难道要写一个 for 循环吗？给我一个 scan 和一个 reduce，我就能为你构建整个世界。总之，非常感谢你，Doug。这绝对是我认为录制时间最长的一次记录。
I mean, we've done two hours plus before. I didn't think we would ever break it, but I guess. This is what the dog thinks, the length of the recording. She's like, can you stop and take me out now take me for a walk now oh yeah thank you so much this has been an absolute blast i know for a fact i mean whatever i call it the c plus plus ox story with doug gregor whatever clickbaity title i find for the first couple episodes they're going to be our best in a while Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com
我的意思是，我们之前录过两个多小时。我没想到我们会打破它，但我猜。这就是狗狗的想法，录音的长度。她好像在说，你能停下来带我出去，现在带我去散步吗？哦，是的，非常感谢，这绝对是一次非常愉快的经历。我确定，我的意思是，无论我怎么称呼它，比如“Doug Gregor 的 C++ 往事”，或者我为前几集找到的任何吸引眼球的标题，它们都将是我们一段时间内最好的作品。请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上
for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是“混乱中夹杂着信息”。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。